it's nearly brand new but this a350
aircraft has already been grounded for
problems with its paint surface qatar
airways says there's an issue with its
a350s
the gulf carrier has grounded 21 of its
fleet for what it calls surface
degradation and other issues which may
compromise the aircraft's lightning
protection system qatar airways has sued
airbus in the uk seeking more than 600
million dollars in compensation it also
wants an investigation it's
unprecedented we hear this word so often
but for us to be witnessing the very
public fallout of what is the largest
aircraft manufacturer in the world right
now airbus with one of their most
prominent customer airlines qatar
airways is something that we haven't
seen of this scale
in previous examples in commercial
aviation history and it's also
escalating
qatar airways has halted delivery of any
more a350s until the problem is fixed on
thursday it asked the high court in
england for an expedited hearing to
address its concerns the next day airbus
cancelled a separate order worth 6
billion
for 50 a 321 neo aircraft to be
delivered next year this is an aircraft
the 321 that many airlines want to grab
and i think airbus know that by doing
this by terminating the order which is
what they said they have done there are
many airlines that will be trying to
grab those slots and skip the queue to
get those 320 ones in of course airbus
in that statement last night
saying that they continue to maintain
the same line which is that they insist
the whole issue is something that isn't
safety related at least five other
airlines have discovered surface flaws
in their a350s according to an
investigation by reuters but qatar
airways is the only one to ground its
fleet forcing it to borrow planes from
other airlines and bring others back
into service european regulators issued
a warning last year that patches of the
lightning protection system may have
been wrongly fitted on some jets but say
they found no evidence of a safety issue
furthermore airbus says there is no
reasonable or rational basis for qatari
regulators who've called the problem
disturbing to have grounded the planes
it's accusing the airline of engineering
the dispute for financial reasons as the
industry continues to deal with the
economic fallout of the pandemic
it's an unusually public spat between
aviation heavyweights caterways has
accused airbus of destroying their
relationship the question now is where
will the airline get its new jets
andrew chappelle al jazeera doha